اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم مقتلوا جندي اسرائيلي
وجرح سبعه بينهم ضابط في عمليه دهس غربا
رام الله وتفجير عبوه ناسفه شرق نابلس
وقوات الاحتلال تذهب منزل عائله المشتبه
به في تنفيذ عمليه الدهس بينما اصيب اكثر
من 90 فلسطينيين خلال التصدي لاقتحام
مستوطنين بحمايه قوات الاحتلال منطقه قبر
يوسف في نابلس
المجلس العسكري في النيجر يقرر سحب
الحصانه الممنوحه للسفير الفرنسي ويامر
الشرطه بترحيله وعائلته الى خارج البلاد
بعدما رفضت فرنسا مغادرته وباريس تقول ان
الانقلابيين في النيجر ليس لديهم سلطه
مطالبه سفيرها بالمغادره وان اعتماد
السفير في النيجر يعود حصرا للسلطات
المنتخبه
ودولي بانقلاب الجابون قائد الحرس
الجمهوري بريس اوليج يؤدي للقسم رئيسا
للمرحله الانتقاليه ومسؤول سياسه الخارجيه
في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل ينتقد
اداره الرئيس علي بونغو للانتخابات
الاخيره ويحمله جزئيا مسؤوليه مالت اليه
الاوضاع
فرنسا تبدا في حظر ارتداء الفتيات للعباء
في المدارس التي تديرها الدوله وسط جدل
واصوات رافضه وذلك التربيه والتعليم ان
التلميذات اللاتي يرتدين العباءه لن يتمكن
من دخول صفوف الدراسيه اعتبارا من الاسبوع
الاول من بدايه هذا العام الدراسي بدعوى
ان العلمانيه التي هي احدى القيم الاساسيه
للمدارس الجمهوريه تحضر ارتداء اي رموز
ذات دلاله دينيه الى اللقاء